MAX SALTONSTALL:
This week, we're
talking about the essentials
of reliability engineering
and how to improve identity
and access management.
I'm Max Saltonstall.
Welcome to "This Week in
Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
So your app is
scaling up swiftly
to meet audience adoption.
Great.
But continuing to add
engineers to your ops team--
not so great.
This week, hear the story
of how Google originally
solved this problem
as our own network
grew by developing
an intuitive set
of site-reliability
engineering principles.
Then spare yourself
the trial and error,
and learn from our mistakes.
When it comes to
application security,
your safety relies on
managing who in your org
gets access to which resources.
But the right answers
aren't always obvious.
Read about applying the
principles of least privilege
to improve your
security posture.
Learn our top tips for
minimizing the surface
area of exposed
applications, and see
which can make the biggest
difference for you.
Speaking of access, the new
Identity and Access Management
recommender for GCP
can automatically
detect overly permissive
access policies.
Then it generates
suggested adjustments
to your permissions
based on the access
patterns of similar people
in your organization.
Read the full article to
learn how recommenders work,
then try them out yourself.
The discovery and
assessment phase
of cloud migration
projects tends
to predict whether the
migration will succeed or fail.
Read this post to learn
about two tools that
can make a big difference--
StratoZone and RISC Networks.
Then head over to
the walkthroughs
to see how each one
works in practice.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any questions?
Leave a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.